[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about something that
I've been thinking about for a long time
and that is the true role that the
Angels play in the hierarchy of the
Dragon Ball super multiverse now
officially we have been told that the
Angels act as assistants or attendants
to the gods of destruction and of course
there are also teachers and guides for
the gods of destruction the angels are
not gods themselves although they do
possess godly key and they are said to
be significantly stronger than even the
gods of destruction when during the
universe survival saga we learned that
the angels are the only beings that will
not be erased along with their universes
we explains this by saying that his
position as an angel is different than
the position of the other deities and
all other beings in the universes we
know that the angels are extremely
powerful they have both destructive
power like the gods of destruction and
the power of creation like the supreme
Kai's as we saw back when vados easily
and quickly created the entire battle
arena for the Martial Arts Tournament
between universes 6 and 7 we also know
that we's can even turn back time for up
to 3 minutes which is an incredibly
powerful and useful ability and if you
think back throughout the series we have
been given clues that the angels are
unique and that they might have a hidden
purpose that even the supreme Kai's and
gods of destruction don't know about
after re-watching all of Dragon Ball
super recently and going through the
clues episode by episode I finally have
a theory for what the true purpose and
role of the Angels is and why they're
unique and different from every other
being in the universe as they inhabit if
you enjoyed the Dragon Ball super
content on this channel be sure to leave
a like to let me know and if you are new
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell also we just created a
poll on Twitter about what type of
Dragon Ball super video
you wanna see in the future on this
channel so if you wanna weigh in and
help us decide be sure to follow us on
Twitter and vote in the poll on top of
that we are now posting daily on
Instagram so if you use Instagram you
can follow us at anime uproar now if you
look at episode 41 in particular the
episode in which we first formally meet
the Omni Kings a no you will see that
even though the supreme Kai's and beerus
and champa bow down deeply to Zeno the
Angels wheeze and vados do not wheeze
and vados also talked to Zeno casually
almost like a friend or colleague
whereas the other deities talk to Xena
with great formality and they are
shocked when Goku talks to him in a
casual tone you can see here that the
Supreme Kai's are prostrating themselves
in front of Zeno which is the biggest
sign of respect in Japanese culture and
the gods of destruction while not
prostrating on the ground are still
bowing very deeply again a major sign of
respect in Japan but the angels are not
bowing and are very casual and relaxed
in front of Zeno we see the same thing
again when Zeno contact Suisse and
beerus later on in the series and asked
them to bring goku to his palace
be disposed deeply but we snot at most
we snots his head slightly at Zeno and
again he talks to Zeno quite casually so
this is a pattern that we are seeing
over and over again in the series now I
am NOT saying that the Angels don't
respect xenos authority they certainly
do and so does the Grand Prix's but it
is clear that the level of formality and
reverence that is expected from the
other deities towards enno is not
expected from the Angels emphasizing
again that the Angels have a special
status I have seen some people comment
on my other Dragon Ball super videos
that we shouldn't look too much into the
details of the series because the
creators of Dragon Ball super don't give
that much thought to the story and just
kind of make it up as they go but from
the example of the Angels it is very
clear that from the beginning Dragon
Ball super has been hinting that there
is something special about them they
have a unique
Attis and a unique purpose the one angel
that we know the most about is of course
we because he is the universe seven
angels so let's look at his actions for
a moment while we certainly does a lot
for beetles in his role as the attendant
he also makes important decisions on his
own we stew sides to personally train
Vegeta and Goku to mortals from universe
7 and at one point beerus asks Wiis why
he is training them and whether he is
actually training with Jenna and Goku to
replace him as the god of destruction
the question here is does we strain
Vegeta and Goku just for fun or does he
have a hidden motive is he trying to
replace beerus i don't think so but I do
think that we's has an important reason
for spending his time training to mere
mortals back when beerus was explaining
to everyone why he was lying to goku
that Monica was strong and of course
beerus was doing this to motivate Goku
to get stronger we sworn to everyone
that if Goku doesn't get stronger the
earth could be in danger because some
other gods of destruction are dangerous
now we are not sure why exactly he says
this but one thing is certain
we's seems to genuinely care about the
well-being of universe 7 and he takes
direct action to help universe 7 from
turning back time to save the earth from
Frieza to training Vegeta and Goku to
warning future beerus about the masu in
order to restore the future timeline
Wiest was also very concerned about
forming the strongest possible team for
the tournament of power to the point
that he used magic to make bull monkey
of birth so that vegeta could enter the
tournament without having to wait for
boma to deliver the baby although we
usually tries to portray himself as
neutral and as if he doesn't have a
personal attachment to beerus and
universe 7 because he is simply doing
his job as an angel
during the tournament of power he does
show great interest in the universe 7
team and he clearly wants universe 7 to
win however the way that the Angels feel
about their own universes does not
appear to be consist
and the tournament proves this when
universe 9 was erased the universe 9
angel Mojito actually smirked as if he
was pleased that this happened on the
other hand when universe 10 was erased
it's angel coos was clearly upset and
sad at the outcome we also saw that when
universe 6 was erased vados was upset as
well and as I said before we squarely
wants his universe to win but why is
there such a difference between the
Angels when it comes to whether or not
they care about their respective
universes I believe that this has
everything to do with the hidden role
and purpose that the Angels actually
play beyond just being the attendance to
the gods of destruction at this point it
is time to talk about the mortal level
immortal level is a metric by which the
twelve universes are ranked and this
level indicates the quality of the
mortals that live in each universe
beyond just the physical strength of
mortals the mortal level judges how
advanced the civilizations are in each
universe how developed their cultures
are and so on the mortal level of each
universe has a lot to do with how
effective their deities the supreme kai
and the god of destruction are in
promoting the development of quality
civilizations while rooting out the
faulty ones the four universes with the
highest moral level were exempt from
taking part in the tournament of power
while the eight universes with the
lowest levels were forced to fight in
the tournament with the seven losing
universes being erased now here is the
big question who is in charge of
determining each universes mortal level
obviously it can't be the Supreme Kai or
the god of destruction because they are
directly responsible for each universes
performance so they could not judge
objectively since every Supreme Kai and
god of destruction wants their universe
to rank as high as possible could Z know
himself be the one who determines the
mortal level of
univers this is very unlikely because to
determine the mortar level of a universe
you have to closely monitor the
countless civilizations throughout each
universe and we already know that Zeno
has no interest in doing that in fact
Zeno pays so little attention to what is
happening within the different universes
that he did not realize what the masa
was doing to the future timeline until
he was summoned by Goku and at that
point Zeno concluded that the timeline
was so corrupted that it needed to be
erased and yet future Seto apparently
did nothing when the masa was killing
the supreme Kai's and the gods of
destruction
proving that Zeno is not paying enough
attention to each universe to determine
its mortal level the grand priest also
seems to have very little knowledge of
universe 7 when he first meets Goku and
Solis invites him to visit sometime and
I think this demonstrates that the grand
priest is not the one who is paying
close attention to each universe and
determining its mortal level either so
what if the Angels have a hidden purpose
and that hidden purpose is that on top
of being the attendants of the gods of
destruction they must also monitor their
respective universe in order to
determine its mortal level the angels
are in a sense like judges who judge the
worth of their universe and then passed
that judgment on to Zeno this would
explain a lot it would explain why the
angels tend to appear neutral and above
the fray and why they tend to act like
they don't feel a personal connection to
their respective universe their job is
to be impartial and to judge and
evaluate each universe objectively just
like a teacher's job is to give an
impartial grade to their students rather
than base their grades on how much they
like each student personally so while
some angels like mojito might not like
their universe so they don't much care
if the universe is erased and while
other angels do care because they do
like their universe ultimately the
angels have to do their best to be
objective when it comes to determining
the Mortal levels of each you
we know that Biru sleeps a lot and that
wheeze sometimes goes off on his own he
is shown coming to earth on his own
without bills and an episode 44 while
Goku is training at King Kai's King Kai
asks him why he doesn't just go and
train with weeks
Goku replies that wheeze had to leave
somewhere but he doesn't mention beerus
leaving so it is possible that we spent
off to do something on his own and this
something could be to monitor the
civilizations of universe 7 to determine
their current mortal level or perhaps he
left in order to report the current
mortal level to Zeno this would also
explain why we worked so hard to train
Goku and Vegeta even though his job is
to be impartial and to give a fair
Mortal ranking for universe 7 he likes
and cares about his universe and this is
why he decides to intervene in a limited
capacity in order to help his universe
and part of that is training Goku and
Vegeta to become stronger we seize their
potential right away and even though
making just two individuals stronger is
not going to change the more the level
of universe 7 by much by making them
stronger we scheme universe 7 a much
better fighting chance in the tournament
of power so while angels like mojito who
don't care about their universe will
simply report the mortal level of their
universe to Z no without interfering
angels like we can make some limited
impact on their universe let's not
forget that even the grand priest was
impressed with Goku when he first met
him and it is also clear that the grand
priests and the angels knew that the
eight lowest ranked universes were going
to get erased vatos even said so in
episode 85 when she told everyone that
they should be grateful that Goku
convinced Zeno to hold the tournament of
power the tournament actually gave the
eight lowest ranked universes of
fighting chance because otherwise they
would have been just erased anyway so if
the Angels including Weez
that at some point soon the universe's
were about to be erased but he also knew
that Goku and Vegeta had great potential
and he saw that even the grand priest
was impressed with Goku it makes perfect
sense for him to work so hard to train
Goku and Vegeta in order to give
universe 7 the best fighting chance
possible and that is my theory all the
Angels have a secret purpose beyond just
serving as attendants to the gods of
destruction fare ultimate role is to
objectively determine the mortal level
of their respective universes and to
report the results to Zeno this idea of
the angels being judges who determined
the value of each universe would explain
a lot including why the Angels don't
need to treat Zeno with the same amount
of formality as the other deities Zeno
personally trusts the angels to judge
the worth of each universe which makes
them his confidants and part of his
inner circle but let me know what you
guys think do the Angels have a hidden
purpose beyond just serving as
attendants and is that purpose to
objectively determine the mortal level
of each universe if so what do you think
that means for the story as draggable
super goes on and if you don't agree
with this theory that's fine too feel
free to tell me what you think the true
purpose of the Angels is down in the
comments if you enjoyed these types of
videos I want to see more be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
don't forget to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar to stay in
touch with all the latest happenings on
the channel as always thank you all so
much for watching thank you for all of
the support and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]